mon projet ça rapporte à ses idées
inventive modestes soit améliorer notre
confort au quotidien ou apporter de
réelles solutions pour mieux partager
nos ressources
parmi ces multitude d'idées inventive il
en est une en particulier dont on
pourrait vous parler ce soir car elle
concerne un élément absolument vital non
nous sommes tous dépendants et dont la
disponibilité est préoccupante
l'eau l'eau et à l'eau aujourd'hui
appelée l'or bleu tant que les rares et
pourtant la planète est recouverte à 70%
d'eau dit comme ça ça paraît énorme et
vue d'une manière plus proportionnelle
par rapport à la taille du groupe voici
ce que ça donne c'est beaucoup moins
impressionnant de ses 70 % de couverture
pas pour cent seulement n'est pas de
l'eau salée et de ses 3 % les deux tiers
sont sous forme de glace et glaciers les
banquises les neiges éternelles
au final les minuscules petites sphères
que vous distinguer à peine en dessous
qui fait 60 km de diamètre constituent
le réservoir d'eau disponible pour le
vivant sur la planète le vivant c'est
donc l'humain est aussi l'animal et le
végétal et cette petite serre est en
danger
chaque année nous livre son lot de
nouvelles alarmantes les températures la
montée du niveau des océans ont battu
des records en 2015 faisant faisant
cette année la pire de toutes
l'histoire moderne une tendance qui
semble se confirmer en 2016 puisque les
six premiers mois de cette année ont été
de loin les plus chauds jamais
enregistrés sur le globe
l'onu estime qu'en 2025
dans moins de dix ans c'est à dire
demain
63 % de la population mondiale sera
confrontée un stress hydrique
autrement dit une réserve d'eau
insuffisante pour subvenir aux simples
besoins vitaux d'une partie de
l'humanité
face à cela certains gouvernements ont
pris la décision de légiférer pour nous
imposer une réduction de notre
consommation d'eau après six années de
sécheresse l'état de californie est un
pionnier dans ses prises de décision
extrême d'autres nations sont en cours
de réflexion
et si aucune solution cohérente et
abordable n'est trouvée rapidement
ce soit va s'imposer de lui-même pour
tenter d'éviter des conflits liés à la
pénurie d'eau face à cette réalité
nous devons tous prendre conscience de
l'urgence absolue de rationaliser notre
consommation d'eau tout au moins c'est
cette la gaspiller l'irrigation des
cultures à un seul camp utilisent 80% de
notre réservoir de 12 planétaire les 20%
restants étant consommée par l'homme et
l'industrie donc la solution qui coule
de source
si j'ose dire et donc dans cette dans la
rationalisation de cette eau
d'irrigation
si nous parvenons à économiser 2 fut ce
que 10% de ces 80% alors nous sommes en
mesure d'inverser tendance qui apparaît
aujourd'hui comme une
or à bhl les technologies modernes
permettent d'économiser de l'eau va
permettre d'économiser beaucoup d'eau en
donnant aux plantes juste ce dont elles
ont besoin
grâce à ses solutions ses solutions
technologiques des essais scientifiques
ont démontré qu'on était en capacité
d'économiser jusqu'à 50 % d'eau par
rapport à une irrigation gérer
stupidement par des horloges programme
et ses programmateurs que vous
connaissez tous le problème étant avec
ses solutions
on dit que le finalement ou à la
solution est là on a trouvé mais non
c'est pas si simple
parce que ces solutions high tech sont
d'une part très compliqué à utiliser et
d'autre part et c'est c'est beaucoup
plus grave elles sont inaccessibles
financièrement pour 95 % des
utilisateurs
elles sont donc réserver ses solutions
technologiques de à de rares oasis tels
que nos splendides green de golf
il existe d'autres solutions dont une
que j'ai développé et mis au point et
qui conforte le fait que les solutions
technologiques ont une limite en termes
de coûts et de complexité
par rapport aux résultats attendus
cette solution chez bien au point est
une solution dite de base technologie
low-tech et permet de vous permettez moi
de convaincre en vous racontant une
petite histoire
d'abord peut-être me présente encore une
fois bernard balèze je suis je baigne
depuis une trentaine d'années dans la
mécanique artistique des fluides
je suis né et j'ai grandi les pieds dans
le sol un peu créatif certainement un
peu rêveur aussi mais bien conscient
qu'on a qu'une seule maison qu'il faut
absolument éviter qu'elle
rule donc il faut trouver des solutions
il y à quelques décennies de cela un
proche parent posséder une bergerie en
haute provence dans le sud de la france
donc accroché à la montagne dans la
rocaille et cette bergerie était
enrichie d'une petite cuvette limon un
terrain propice à des cultures est un
trésor sur place c'était une source qui
connaît depuis le haut de la montagne
qui avait quitté los était canalisée
jusqu au cabanon et c'est une eau qui
coulait à profusion toute l'année
isolement du lieu ne permettant pas de
raccordement au réseau électrique et son
propriétaire venant profiter de sa
villégiature que deux mois par an il m'a
été confiée de trouver une solution pour
maintenir le potager en bonne état de
production mais de manière autonome
évidemment sans quoi j'allais me
retrouver condamné à monter un pied dans
la montagne tous les matins rosés sont
foutus potager et ça il en était pas
question donc comment je me suis pris
j'ai pris une valve tout simplement que
j'ai raccordé au l'arrivée d'eau de
cette source
il donne avec une manette en simple
quart de tour comme ça à laquelle j'ai
connecté en son milieu
une barre de fer avec du fil de fer j'ai
nourri star et ça constitue et un
balancier qui permettait d'ouvrir et de
fermer l'eau d'un côté du balancier j'ai
installé un contrepoids et de l'autre
des crozes réponse de ménage en prenant
soin que l'ensemble du système ou
dispositif se trouve sous le rayon
d'arrosage dans les asperseurs du jardin
si bien que lorsque le jardin était
arrosé mais éponge l'était aussi l
s'alourdissait du poids de l'eau et
finalement basculé 20 d'annette enfants
et ma vanne en position de faire
pour l'arrosage ensuite selon le climat
très simplement les réponses s'évaporait
s'alléger de l'europe de l'euro
exactement de la même manière que le
seul concerné et finalement refusé
basculer dans le sens de l'ouverture
d'un nouveau cycle eau d'irrigation nous
obtenions un système simple peu coûteux
s'il omet de contrôle climatique de
l'arrosage
après six mois d'absence que vous sommes
revenus sur les lieux nous avons
constaté que le rendement du potager
avait littéralement explosé
l'expérience a en outre démontré tout à
fait accessoirement que ce système
économiser de l'eau alors même que dans
les années 80 l'idée d'une pénurie
globale d'eau liées à un réchauffement
climatique tenait de la science fiction
tout au moins sinon du pur délire et
depuis ces dernières années j'ai
affiné ce système pour le rendre
accessible à tous
utilisable sous toutes les latitudes et
en tout saisonnalité ou la barre de fer
balancier fil de fer rouillé a été
remplacé maintenant par une vanne a
comme une vanne magnétique qui est
actionné par un aimant permanent
c'est une énergie gratuite pour des
milliers d'années les quais l'être
humain est associé un flotteur très
simple les éponges ont été remplacés par
un élément en céramique poreuse beaucoup
plus compact et aussi payant une
meilleure réponse par rapport à la
demande réelle des sols et l'ensemble
est adaptable à toutes et à tous les
types de cultures toutes les tailles de
culture et peu coûteux et ne nécessite
aucune connexion électrique donc
adaptable sur des pays dits en voie de
développement qui en ont le plus besoin
et donc et donc le système s'installe en
mode plug and play sur un réseau
d'irrigation j'aime bien le monde le
gameplay savait très high tech
ce système est opérationnel et 6 en
nouvelle calédonie et il a été mis en
test auprès de l'institut agronomique
calédonien sous sa supervision
un test comparatif qui a permis de
démontrer l'économie de 34 % d'eau par
rapport à un système programme est
pourtant réglé au plus juste par des
scientifiques
un autre test vient juste de se terminer
sur les espaces verts de la ville de
nouméa et là nous avons su démontrer une
économie d'eau de plus de 70% par
rapport à la programmation actuelle
si vous passez dans vous constaterez que
les pelouses sont au moins aussi verte
qu'avant cette solution a reçu le prix
de l'innovation au salon international
de l'irrigation de los angeles en
novembre dernier et pour moi c'était une
chance extraordinaire parce que ça m'a
ouvert les portes dès le lendemain des
portes jusque là hermétiquement closes
j'ai été reçu par le gouvernement
californien en charge de l'eau le water
board qui m'a fait part de son réel
intérêt pour cette solution de par sa
simplicité son autonomie et son coup et
cela m'a ouvert les portes d'une
université spécialisée en irrigation
comme l'université de davis de riverside
et déteste maintenant sont en marche
pour être performer pour être publiés
dans des revues scientifiques
je suis en contact actuellement aussi
avec des entités internationales comme
comme le rhénus tour parce que je suis
convaincue mais je dois aussi convaincre
que un système aussi simple que celui là
qui défie les systèmes de haute
technologie est capable en toute
humilité d'apporter sa petite goutte
d'eau un rééquilibrage lyderic globale
pour finir je voudrais partager un rêve
avec vous essayez d'imaginer ce même
système sur une échelle bien plus vaste
en plein milieu d'un désert puisque le
caractère autonome du système le permet
ou une sélection de graines de plantes
annuelles de buissons et d'arbres
pourrait germer croître s'étendre
recréer un écosystème devenir une forêt
qui ramènerait naturellement la pluie je
travaille sur ce projet actuellement en
attendant le temps est compté et nous
devons tous changer nos comportements
sinon le changement nous sera imposé